uh yes uh the the obr U-turn you're
referring to uh the bringing forward of
the obr's independent forecast and the
government's uh medium-term plan uh I
think is really important because it has
the opportunity now provided it's all
credible and it Stacks up to settle the
markets and what that can do is to take
some of the pressure off these Rising
interest rates
um to the extent we don't know the
timing uh of when the government's going
to come forward with these yet but uh if
it is before the monetary policy
committee meeting on the 3rd of November
then that will also have the benefit of
informing their decision on how high
they uh raised the base rate and to the
extent that that uh forecast lands well
with the markets and to the extent that
that in turn means the expectations of
where inflation is going is a little bit
more benign then that too will allow
them potentially at least to come
forward with a lower increase than would
otherwise be the case and that will
matter hugely to millions of people up
and down the country three that have a
mortgage I actually meant the 45p raped
and but that one works as well
um we have seen a U-turn from a prime
minister who said basically modeling
herself on Mrs Thatcher the ladies not
for turning and she also has not ruled
out this morning are you turning some
more meantime the Justice secretary said
the rest of the mini budget will be
delivered as is is this government in
sync
I think it's in a very very difficult
position because what it's done is it's
come forward with a very large uh level
of unfunded tax cuts it's now having to
look very closely at how it's going to
fund those and there are three ways you
can do it one is you can grow the
economy which is clearly the primary
Mission but they'll have to convince the
obr that they can do that quite
aggressively and I suspect that probably
the forecast won't reflect that
um it'll affect some growth but but not
enough uh the second way that you can do
it is leaning into spending so cutting
spending well that's going to be quite
difficult in a high inflationary
environment where departmental budgets
in real terms have already been cut
um and uh or you back away from some of
the tax cuts that you've been uh
proposing and we've seen some of that
already but the the dropping of the um
45p rate reversal on that only takes
about 2 billion out of what was 45
billion pounds worth of tax cuts so
there's a long way to go so this tension
between holding the line on tax and
coming forward politically viable uh
Cuts in expenditure is going to be
really tense indeed and very difficult
to square I think but we have to see
what the government comes through with
with its plan
yeah the other elephants in the room
um is what's going to happen as far as
benefits are concerned your man said
that they would go up with inflation
suggestion now is that they might go up
with um with wages and that's that's the
difference between five and a half
percent and a ten percent increase in
benefits uh one wonders what
backbenchers might do about that
I think they're going to find that
extraordinarily difficult and one of the
things that hasn't been focused on
actually is what happened to benefits
when they were upgraded last time around
now when we say upright rated by
inflation the way it works is they're
upgraded in the April but they're pegged
to whatever the inflation rate was back
in the previous September now last April
the inflation rate in the previous
September was just 3.1 percent in other
words already well below where inflation
was at that particular moment in time so
in a sense we'd be looking at real terms
cut against a background of a pretty
tough settlement last time around so I
think colleagues are are going to
struggle with this and this could be one
of those areas where the government's
going to have to think again
so you mean a u-turn
uh potentially uh I I think that that's
potentially the case well one of the
things that I would say is you're seeing
a very rapid shifting in positions uh
Happening Here some of these measures of
calls won't actually come before the
common still much further down the line
because they actually need uh
legislation so these may be uh battles
that occur you know some time from now
even into the early part of next year
but
um yeah I I think the pressure on this
is going to be very difficult from the
back benches towards the government
um she won though didn't she I mean that
she is the woman she is the leader that
conservatives wanted at number 10 dining
street so isn't now the time that the
party should get behind her and support
her as she tries to get the economy back
uh on a Level Playing Field
yeah absolutely
um so we should all be running behind
the Prime Minister but we need to be
doing that on the basis that we have
broadly a plan that is fiscally credible
uh that is politically deliverable and I
think that's what we're searching our
way towards if I can put it that way uh
at the moment but absolutely the best of
all outcomes for the country and also
for the conservative party is for us to
have a major reset moment particularly
when this obr forecast comes forward and
the plan is presented the Market's
getting more confidence now fiscal
credibility and then moving forward as a
party uh to Awards the next general
election you know if we can do that we
need to do it in steps because a long
way behind at the moment big challenges
then you know I think there's a chance
uh that we can have a positive outcome
in a couple of years time but there's a
lot of work to be done given that
everybody should be getting behind the
Prime Minister what did you mean when
you said the government has to date felt
far too Doctrine air
so exactly this point that I'm making
about the importance of pragmatism so I
welcome the uh the change intact on the
45p rate I welcome the fact that there's
been a change in tack on bringing
forward the uh the government's uh
proposals and the obr uh forecast and
it's that pragmatism that we need to see
going forward because politics is the
art of the possible and there is no
point in going forward with measures
which frankly are just not going to
um you know survive impact with uh back
benches for example or indeed the public
more generally in some cases so we need
uh that pragmatism that we've seen
recently to keep going
to that end what on Earth is Michael
Gove up to you backed him in 2019 to be
a leader of course didn't you he's
running around being a thorn in this
PM's side
well um I I don't know what exactly
Michael's up to in the sense that I you
know I don't hang out with Michael Gove
all the time that I have huge respect uh
for him I I think if you're referring to
the fact that he came out quite strongly
against the 45p raid
um then I think broadly he was right to
do that and uh of course there has been
a change of approach and I think uh all
of us in the conservative party we want
the same thing we want the government to
be successful uh we want to do the right
thing for the country and we some of us
have quite strong views on that that
we're going to make known uh as as we go
along and that was an example of Michael
doing just that and in fact I think uh
where he pushed and how he pushed uh was
probably quite constructive in that way
in in leading us to a point where we've
now moved away from a policy that I just
don't think in the current environment
was politically tenable okay uh you're
in central London at the moment are you
joining me on the train to Birmingham
for the leader speech tomorrow
no and not because uh of uh in any sense
boycotting the conference from my point
of view I took a decision many months
ago uh that uh this conference is not
one that that I'd be attending
um there are various family things that
we've had planned around some personal
events uh for the family and that's why
so uh nothing to be read into that okay
although lots of your colleagues uh
high-profile colleagues um are also not
there including our other chairman of
select committees others that were very
high profile cabinet ministers
previously shouldn't they be there
showing support to your new prime
minister
I think there's an overestimation of uh
what sort of number of back bench MPS
typically go to conferences actually I
think that's that's one point but uh for
each and every one of uh of those people
that's that's a decision for them and I
I can't speculate as to why they've
decided uh to go or not on on this
occasion